ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์
ค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่
27 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะอีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ค่ะมีพ.ศ
ปีคศต.ยคะดีค่ะ
2022 ค่ะพี่ค่ะ
2022 นะคะตอนนี้เวลา
มีกี่โมงตอนนี้เวลา
16:30  4 นาทีค่ะ
4:34 นาทีนะคะ I ค่ะ
วันนี้มิอะไร
ครูเอ๋มีคำถามไหมครับตอนนี้ครูเอ๋ยังไม่
มีคำถามนักเรียน
5 แต่ครูเอ๋รู้คู่หญิงมีอะไรให้ครูเอ๋ดู
ใช่ไหมตาดู
ใครค่ะครูผู้หญิงมีรูปให้ครูเอ๋เอ๋ดูให้
ครูเอ๋ดูนะคะใส่เข้าอะไรคะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋ดู
ค่ะ
นี่ค่ะค่ะรูป
รูปนี้มีคนเช่านะคะใช่ค่ะรูปนี้มีคนมีคน
กี่คนคะมีคน 2 คนค่ะมีคนสองคนมีผู้ชายกี่
คนมีผู้ชายหนึ่งคน
มีผู้หญิงกี่คนดีผู้หญิง 1 คนมากผู้ชาย
ใส่เสื้อ
แขนสั้น
หรือแขนยาว
ผู้ชายใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
เสื้อใช่ไหมเสื้อผู้ชายใส่เสื้อแขนยาวค่ะ
รูปสักครู่นะคะยายค่ะอันนี้อะไรคะ
เล็กไทยค่ะผู้ชายผูกผูก
หนัง x ไทยนะคะไดร์ค่ะอ่ารับผู้ชายใส่
อะไรคะผู้ชายใส่กางเกงขายาวค่ะใหม่กางเกง
ขายาวอ่ะผู้หญิงใส่อะไรคะ
ผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อแขนยาวค่ะผู้หญิงมีเนคไท
ไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่มีเนคไทค่ะก็แล้วผู้หญิง
ใส่อะไรคะอันนี้ผู้หญิงใส่กระโปรงค่ะไก่
กระโปรงราคากระโปรงสั้นหรือกระโปรงยาว
กระโปรงสั้นค่ะกระโปรงสั้นนะคะพระอันนี้
เป็นกระโปรงยาวเขา
ชนิดกระโปรงยาวนะคะอะกระโปรงสั้นนะคะพี่
สาวมีรูปรูปที่ 1 กับผู้หญิงมีอะไรคะอัน
นี้ในฆ่ากูเองก็มีรองเท้าค่ะรองเท้าผู้
ชายมีรองเท้าไหมคะผู้ชายมีรองเท้าค่ะมี
รองเท้า
สองคน
กำลังทำอะไรคะสองคนกำลังยิ้มค่ะยิ้มราคา
กีมทรายโอเคมีรูปอีกไหมคะนี่ค่ะครูเอ๋
รูปที่ 2
รูปอะไรก็เห็นไหมเห็นค่ะเอาเห็นโอเคกะ
กูเองถามใช่ไหมตัวเอกครูเอ๋ถามดีค่ะ
พากย์ผู้หญิงที่รูปนี้มีผู้ชายกี่คนใน
ว่าพวกมีผู้ชาย
122 คนค่ะมีผู้ชายอ่ะ 2 คนนะคะค่ะ
2 ผู้ชาย 2 คน
มีผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายผมสีดำ
กี่คนผู้ชายผมสีดำนักสีดำ 1 คนค่ะผมสีดำ
นะคะผู้ชายผมสีอะไรสีน้ำตาลกี่คอนผู้ชาย
ผมสีน้ำตาล 1 คนผมสีน้ำตาลคนนี้นะคา
433 คนค่ะมีผู้หญิง 1  2  3  3 คนผู้
หญิงผมยาวกี่คนคะผู้หญิงผมยาว 2 คนค่ะ
หนึ่งสองนะคะผมยาวสองคนมีผู้หญิงผมสั้น
ผมสั้น
ผมสั้นกี่คนคะมีผู้หญิงผมสั้น 1 คนค่ะผู้
หญิงผมสั้น 1 คนนี่คนทั้งหมดกี่คนคะมีคน
ทั้งหมด 1  2  3  4  4  5  5 5คนค่ะมีคน
ทั้งหมด 5 คนอาผู้หญิงคะมีหอยมีคน
อาจะใส่กางเกงสีอะไรอ่ะสีน้ำเงินไหมสี
น้ำเงินกางเกงสีน้ำเงินกี่คนคะมีคนใส่
กางเกงสีน้ำเงิน
122 คนค่ะมีคนใส่กางเกงสีน้ำเงิน 2 คนมี
คนใส่เสื้อ
สีเขียว
กี่คนคะมีคนใส่เสื้อสีเขียว 1
122 คนค่ะ 2  2 คนนะคะใส่เสื้อสีเขียว
นะคะอ่าตัวเองรอบของตัวเองด้วยนะโอเคตัว
เองเคลียร์ให้ค่ะ
อานุหมดหรือยังคุยมีคนอ่าใส่เสื้อแขนสั้น
แขนสั้นๆแกะสั้นเสื้อแขนเสื้อสั้นกี่คนคะ
มีคนใส่เสื้อแขนสั้น
2  2 คนค่ะ 2 คนนะคะมีคนใส่เสื้อแขนกุด
กี่คนคะมีคนใส่เสื้อแขนกุด
122 คนค่ะ 2 คนมีคนใส่เสื้อแขนยาวกี่คน
คะจะมีคนใส่เสื้อแขนยาวครูเอ๋เอ๋ใส่เสื้อ
แขนยาวอ้าว
1 คนค่ะ
มีคนใส่กางเกงสีสีเขียวอ่ะ
สวิสสีฟ้า
เขียวสีเขียวสีฟ้า
รวมกัน
กี่คนคะมีคนใส่กางเกงเขียวสีฟ้า
1 คนสองคนสองคนค่ะ 2 คนมีคนใส่แว่นตา
แว่นตา
กี่คนคะมีคนใส่แว่นตา 1 คนค่ะอย่าโอเค
เดี๋ยวแล้ว
มีความจะให้พูดยิ้มกี่เขาโอเคค่ะมีคนยิ้ม
หมู 1
444 คนไหม
5 คนนี้ก็ยิ้มเหรอคะยิ้มอย่างยิ่ง 5 คน
ค่ะค่ะมีมีคนยิ้ม 5 คน
แน่
โอเคมีรูตอบมีรูปอีกไหมคะนี่ค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋
มีค่ะ
รูปนี้มีคนทั้งหมดกี่คนคะรูปนี้มีคนทั้ง
หมด
[เพลง]
4555 คนค่ะหน้าคนมีผู้ชายกี่คนมีผู้ชาย 1
3  3  4  4  4 คนค่ะมีผู้หญิงกี่คนมีผู้
หญิง
1 คนค่ะ 1 คนผู้หญิงคุณใส่เสื้อสีอะไรคะ
ผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อสีชมพูสีชมพูสีชมพู
คู่เอกสีให้ดู
สี
ชมพูค่ะ
ยกขึ้นอ่ะ
ได้ค่ะตรงหน้าครูเอ๋มันจะได้สีชมพูและสี
ส้มสีชมพูสีส้ม
โอเคสีโอโรส
มิมีมีคนถือหนังสือ
กี่คนคะมีคนถือหนังสือ
122 คนค่ะหนังสือสมัยทาง 2014
ถ้ามีคน
โกนผม
ผมเนี่ยแกแอบแอปโกนผมฉัน
กี่คนคะมีคนโกนผมสั้น
1 คนค่ะ 1 คน 1 คน
มีผู้ชายใส่เสื้อ
2 ตัวกี่คนคะมีผู้ชายใส่เสื้อ 2 ตัว
หนึ่งคนค่ะหนึ่งคนนะคะเสื้อเสื้อหนึ่ง
แล้วก็ตัวนี้ 2  2 ตัวมีผู้ชายผมยาวนิด
หน่อยกี่คนคะมีผู้ชายผมยาวมีก็ผมยาวเนาะ
122 คนค่ะ 2 คน
โป้ขามีอะไรอีกมีมีคนมีคน
สะพายกระเป๋ากี่คนคะพี่คน
สะพายกระเป๋า
1  1  2  3  3  4  4  4 คนค่ะ 4 คนโอเค
หมดแล้วหมดแล้วรูปต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
โอ้โห
มีคนทั้งหมดกี่คนคะมีคนทั้งหมด 1  1 นัก
เรียนม
1  1  2  3
4  4  5  5  6
6  7  7  471 คนค่ะเงินทั้งหมด 7 คนนะคะ
ออนมีคนทั้งหมด 7 คนมีคนมีหนวดมีเครากี่
คนคะมีคนมีหนวดมีเครา
1 คนค่ะค่ะนี่คอนนะคะ
มีคน
รัดผม
นัดผมเหมือนครูหญิง
บนคะมีคนรัดผม
1 คนค่ะเนี่ยมีคนผมหยิกกี่คนคะมีคนผม
หยิก
1 คนค่ะเมื่อมีมีคนผมสีทอง
สีบรอนซ์สีทองสีบลอนด์ทองกี่คนคะมีคนผมสี
บรอนซ์ทอง 1 คนค่ะมีคนผมสีน้ําตาลกี่คนคะ
มีคนผมสีน้ำตาล 1
คนค่ะมีคนผมสีดำกี่คนคะมีคนผมสีดำ
122 คนค่ะ
ง้อโอเค
โอเคอะรูปต่อไปค่ะอ่ะกู
มีคนทั้งหมดกี่คน
มีคนทั้งหมด 1
3  34
4  5
6  7
8 คนค่ะ 8 คนคนทั้งหมดอยู่ที่ไหนคะคน
ทั้งหมดอยู่ในสวนค่ะอยู่ในสวน
มีต้นไม้กี่ต้นต้นไม้ดีใหญ่ค่ะมีต้นไม้
ใหญ่
1233 ต้นค่ะมีต้นไม้ใหญ่ 3 ต้นนะคะค่ะมี
ดูก่อนมี
โคมไฟกี่โคมคะมีคมไฟ
[เพลง]
1122 โคมค่ะอีกโคมไฟ 2 โคมมี
เก้าอี้นั่ง
และชาวเพจตัวคะมีเก้าอี้นั่งยาว 1 ตัวค่ะ
หนึ่งตัว
มีอันนี้อะไร
กู๊ตเตอร์ไหมคะอันไหนคะอันที่เป็นร้อน
เดียวหรือว่ามีที่จะมีที่จับ
100r เขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
จักรยาน
คู๋ไม่รู้จักนะคะอ๋อโอเคมีคนกำลัง
อ่ะวิ่ง
กี่คนคะ
ดีคนกำลังใช้ขา
อะไรใช้ขาวิ่งเนี่ย
[เพลง]
1123  3 คนค่ะ
มีคนใส่กางเกง
อาหารสั้นกี่คนคะมีคนใส่กางเกงขาสั้น
3  3 คนค่ะมีคนมีคนดื่มกาแฟกาแฟไหมอ่ะ
โอเคค่ะความหนามีคนดื่มกาแฟ
112 โอ้
3  3 คนค่ะงั้นคนมีคนใส่หูฟัง
ฟังเพลงกี่คนคะมีคนใส่หูฟังฟังเพลง
122 คนค่ะโอเคมีคนมีเป้กี่คนคะมีคนมีเป้
422 คนค่ะง่อมีคนมีหนวดมีเครากี่คนคะมี
คนมีหนวดมีเครา 1 คนค่ะโอเคค่ะหมดคำถาม
ต่อรูปต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋กูโง่โง่
มีคนทั้งหมดกี่คนมีคนทั้งหมด 1
3  4  4  5  5
5คนค่ะคนทั้งหมด 5 คนมีหมา
ทั้งหมดกี่ตัว
มีหมาทั้งหมด
[เพลง]
4444 ตัวค่ะมีหมาทั้งอ่า 4 ตัว
มีเก้าอี้ยาวทั้งหมดกี่ตัวมีเก้าอี้ยาว
ทั้งหมด
122 ตัวค่ะค่ะมีผู้หญิงใส่กระโปรง
กี่คนคะมีผู้หญิงใส่กระโปรง
1 คนค่ะ
กระโปรง
พูดผู้หญิงที่นั่งแล้วก็จับหมานั่งบนอะไร
คะ
นั่งบนเสื่อค่ะนิดเสียเหลือนะคะมีผู้ชาย
เล่นกีตาร์จริงๆกี่คนคะมีผู้ชายเล่น
กีตาร์ 1 คนค่ะมีต้นไม้ใหญ่เกย์ต้นคะมี
ต้นดีและใหญ่
122 ต้นค่ะของต้นนะคะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไร
คะคุย
ต้นย่าค่ะคุณย่ารักตรงนี้ทั้งหมดเรียกว่า
อะไร
สนามหญ้าค่ะอย่างามหญ้านะคะอันนี้เลี้ยง
อะไรคะ
อะไรคะอันนี้
แก้มพุ่มไม้ผมหมายมีผู้ไม้มากๆน้องหล่า
จ่ายโอเค
รูปต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ต่อไปงู
ผู้หญิงคะอันนี้เรียกว่าลืม
อันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะอ่ะหรือทางม้าลายค่ะ
ทางม้าลายอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
ไฟ
ไปดาราจร
ไฟจราจร OK ไฟเขียวไฟแดง
โอเคนะคะนาน
ทางม้าลายมีคนถือกระเป๋าถือนะคะถือกี่คน
ค่ะมีคนถือกระเป๋า
1 คน 2  2 คนค่ะนี่คนสะพายกระเป๋ากี่คน
คะมีคนสะพายกระเป๋า
1 คนค่ะหน้ามีคนใส่รองเท้าส้นสูงกี่คนคะ
มีคนใส่รองเท้าส้นสูง 1 มีคนค่ะอันนี้สูง
มั้ยคะอันนี้สูงเหรอน่าจะเป็นอ่ะมองไม่
เห็นขอโทรศัพท์
2552 มีคน 2 คนค่ะ 2 คนมีคนใส่รองเท้า
Cat  shoes กี่คนคะมีคนใส่รองเท้า Cat
shoes
1231 ทั้ง 3 คนนะ Cat  too หมดกะตะดี่ 5
ทุกคนใส่รองเท้า Cat  shoes ค่ะแต่มีสอง
คนรองเท้าส้น
สูงส้นอันนี้ส้นสูงนะคะ
อามีคนถือถ้วยกาแฟกี่คนคะมีคนถือถ้วยกาแฟ
อีกหนึ่งคนค่ะมีคนหอบแฟ้มกี่คนค่ะมีคนห่อ
แฟ้ม 1 คนค่ะแฟ้มแล้วก็ขอบแฟ้มนะคะมีคน
ใส่เสื้อลายกี่คนคะมีคนใส่เสื้อลาย
122 คนค่ะอันนี้นะคะเสื้อปลายไรนะ
คะโอเคค่ะโอเค
รูปต่อยังๆๆยุงหมากี่คนมีคนจูงหมา 1 คน
ค่ะอยู่ชั้นอันนี้หมา
แล้วก็มีชื่อเรื
[เพลง]
ก็จะได้อีกรูปหนึ่งค่ะยังมีเวลายังมีเวลา
มีคนทั้งหมดกี่คนมีคนทั้งหมด 1
2  2  3  3  4  4  5  5  6  6 คนค่ะ
มิอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้
ไฟอ่ะโคมไฟไฟมีโคมไฟกี่โคมคะมีโคมไฟ 1
2  2  3  3 โคบังค่ะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไร
คะผู้หญิง
ตะกร้าตะกร้ามีคนถือตะกร้ากี่คนคะมีคนถือ
แตกแต่ถ้า
122 คนค่ะมีตะกร้าทั้งหมดกี่ใบคะมี
ตะกร้าทั้งหมด
3 ใบค่ะ 3 ใบนะคะ
คนนี้ทำอัดพุทธผู้หญิงคนนี้นี้ผู้ชายคน
นี้ทำงานอะไรคะผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายทำงานเป็น
แคชเชียร์ค่ะทำงานเป็นแคชเชียร์อ่าแล้วคน
ที่ 1
2  3
มาทำอะไรคะ
คนหนึ่งสองสามสี่คนสี่คนมาซื้อของค่ะซื้อ
ของโต๊ะแคชเชียร์ทำอะไรคะแคชเชียร์เก็บ
เงินเก็บเป็นงานใช่มั้ยฮะเงินอ่ะดอลลาร์
ค่ะเงินนะคะเงินแคชเชียร์เก็บเงินหน้า
ผู้หญิงมี
สับปะรดกี่บาทกี่ลูกอีสับปะรดใช่ไหมชายๆ
ค่ะมีสอบ
กับมี
สับปะรด 1 ลูกค่ะ
สับปะรดนะคะสับปะรด 1 ลูกใส่สัปปะรดอาร์
อาร์มีอะไรอีกมีคำถามอีกนะมี
มีเครื่องคิดเงิน
เครื่องคิดเงินกี่เครื่องคะนี่มีเรื่อง
คิดเงิน 1
2  2 เครื่องค่ะ
มีที่แขวนถุง
พลาสติกกี่ที่คะมีที่แขวนถุงพลาสติก 1
2  2 ที่ค่ะที่นะคะ
ของคุณหมดเวลาหรือพระครูเอ๋หมดเวลาหรือ
ยังกูเองไม่ได้ดูหญิงไม่แน่ใจนะคะอีก 1
รูปแล้วกันค่ะเผื่อไว้
5 โมงเย็นแล้วโอเคอ้ารูปนี้มีกี่คนคะรูป
นี้มี 1  2
3  4  5  5 5คนค่ะที่ไหนคะที่ 5 คนรอ
อยู่ที่ออฟฟิศค่ะผู้หญิงรูปที่แล้ววอยู่
ที่ไหน
ปริญนะคะรูปที่แล้วรูปนี้อยู่ที่
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตค่ะอ่ะรูปต่อไปที่ออฟฟิศ
นะคะ is มีคนยืนกี่คนคะมีคนยืน 1  2  2  3
3  4  4  4 คนค่ะมีคนนั่งกี่คนคะมีคน
นั่ง 1 คนค่ะมีคนเก่าหัวกี่คนคะมีคนเก่า
หัว 1 คนค่ะมีคนเท้าเอว
กี่คนคะมีคนเท้าเอว
2 คนค่ะมีคนใส่เข็มขัดเก๋มีคนคะมีคนใส่
เข็มขัด 1 คนค่ะอยากคุยวงให้เข็มค่ะอัน
นี้เข็มขัดนะคะ
มีคนกำลังทำคอมพิวเตอร์กี่คนคะมีคนกำลัง
ทำคอมพิวเตอร์มีอะคะทำคอมพิวเตอร์
1 คนค่ะ
มีคนใส่สร้อย
มุกกี่คนคะมีคนใส่สร้อยมุก
1 คนค่ะคนโอเคผู้หญิงคิดหมดเวลาแล้วชาย
ค่ะครูเอ๋เนาะวันนี้นะคะก็คลิปนี้ครูหญิง
กับครูเอ๋เจาะไปก่อนนะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
ตั้งค่า